ariana grande comes to Pete Davidson's
defense while the singer and the
comedian may have called off their
whirlwind relationship in October Ari
wants everyone to know that she still
has mad love for her ex as she should
it's pretty fresh off the relationship
so in the middle of the night Ari
Instagram story to urge her fans to lay
off her ex-fiance the message came after
the Saturday Night Live star posted a
highly personal message about the
negativity he received from Aris fans
after she dropped the break-up anthem
thank you next Ari reposted his message
along with some thoughts of her own
writing in part quote I care deeply
about Pete and his health I'm asking you
to please be gentler with others so
please let whatever point you are trying
to make go I will always have
irrevocable love for him and if you've
gotten any other impression from my
recent work you might have missed the
point yeah so I think thank you next was
an anthem for all of us and while she
named drops her exes of course she's
still gonna have love for her ex fiance
things are very fresh like I said before
so Ariana she's doing the right thing
stepping up and telling her fans to cool
down I mean kudos to her yeah and I love
this whole thing I feel like she's just
taking the high road over and over and
over again like let's all learn from Ari
okay so Pete has been very open about
his struggles with mental health in the
past he even noted his message quote
I've been getting online bullied and in
public by people for nine months I've
spoken about bipolar disorder and being
suicidal publicly only in the hopes that
it will help bring awareness and help
kids like myself who don't want to be on
this earth wow that's just a lot how I
know it's so sad but I love that he's
being so open he also went on to note
quote no matter how hard the internet or
anyone tries to make me kill myself
I won't I'm upset I even have to say
this Wow yeah I mean he really is
speaking on something that needs to be
talked about mental health is so
important so I'm glad that he's speaking
out and I'm glad the ariana is
supporting him in the way that she is
because it's nasty it online bullying
has to stop it does it does and et
actually recently sat down with dr. Drew
Pinsky and he weighed in on Pete's
social post it didn't really raise
concern for me but it but it suggests he
may be chronically suicidal right I
don't
to be in this earth a sort of a feeling
that people have when they are
chronically depressed a chronically
suicidal I'm assuming when he says BPD
he means bipolar disorder and not
borderline personality disorder which
struck me as first on other possibility
those people with that disorder often
feel self-destructive and feel that way
as well and to me this was an extremely
courageous note it was spot-on in terms
of I mean a very short message I thought
he delivered his I delivered a punch
he's saying look my ploy disorder is
associated with depression I think you
feel suicidal and I wanted to let other
people know they weren't alone I mean
god bless him for dinner
I am a little concerned for Pete this is
something he struggled with and he's
being very open about it but at the same
time I agree with dr. drew that it's
awesome that he's using his platform
that's what I agree with I mean being a
celebrity is hard enough and for them to
have this perfect persona to speak out
it mean so much to so many people and
Pete if he is struggling it's I think it
helps him and others for him to speak
out so what did you guys think of Pete's
social media post that sound off across
all social so Pete's message comes just
three days after Ari released her
record-breaking music video for thank
you next which of course drops
Davidson's name yep and not only that in
the video she also posts a photo of them
together writing sorry I dipped Pete I
love you always of course I love those
friendly exes now a source recently told
UT that Pete is ready to find love again
in fact how he has signed on to a
popular dating app a source revealed
quote he wants a fresh start he's
focusing on his self happiness
aren't you guys but we want to know what
you think do you think it's too soon for
Pete to be dating again and how much
time do you think he should take to fly
solo to each its own and what do you
guys think of Ariana's message on
Instagram I really thought it was
powerful and necessary but do you think
she did the right thing by defending her
ex let's talk all across social media
I'm at Kourtney underscore tezo now and
I'm at Halle underscore Stephens until
next time we've got you covered